and were you going to have a space in
trun and trump almost gave you a
position or whenever he became president
wasn't there talk of that and then it
kind of went away he just kind of went
into the end of the wind with it
well what happened was he con in
20 over the christmas vacation
um 2016 he's elected right
and then obviously the election isn't in
november
so i was skiing
and with my kids in colorado over
christmas vacation
and i got a call from his chief of staff
saying the president-elect wants to meet
crazy and he wants to talk about
vaccines so
you know i've been an activist on trying
to get safer vaccines for a long time
and of course i agreed to meet with him
so i went to
immediately after getting home i went to
washington or i went to new york
and met with him in trump tower and um
during it was about a two-hour meeting
had you ever met with him before i had
sued him twice before a success okay
and i had met him and you know the the
lawsuit um
was not something that had hurt our
relationship i stopped him from building
two golf courses in the new york city
watershed
about and those lawsuits were about two
or three years apart
so um and he knew me and he knew my
family he would
um when my sister ran for the for
governor of maryland
he made a big contribution to that he
contributed to my brother who was then
in congress and i had a cousin who was a
congressman from rhode island and he
made uh
contributions to that he was a big
democratic donor at that point
he called me he asked me to come in i
had
as i said about a two-hour meeting with
him at that meeting
people were coming in and out of that
meeting so um
so steve bannon was there um
renz priebus you remember him uh
hope hill was there kellyanne conway
and uh and jared kushner
and both the president's sons at various
times were in that meeting
people and he but i had a lot of time
alone with
president trump too he
said that he believed that vaccines were
making people sick specifically he had
three
women friends who were mothers one who
was in the building that day
who had perfectly healthy kids who had
gotten uh
a you know their wellness visits
when they were around two years old and
the the children never were the same
after those visits they all
had been subsequently diagnosed with
autism and he believed
that it was linked to the vaccines
and he you know because he had been open
about that
during the campaign hundreds of women
had as they did the same thing that
happened to me that got me into this
you know this career killing uh
um advocacy vaccine safety obviously
um you know people start coming up to
you and saying
you know this happened to me this
happened to my son i had a perfectly
healthy child
and who exceeded all his milestones and
i took him in at
16 months and he you know he was
speaking he was a toilet trained he had
social interactions and i took him in
and he had a
a shot or a series of shots usually yeah
could be up to nine
yeah and now he's living in a tent at
the circus right afternoon and they
at night he's like fever 103 they have
i mean the stories were yearly all
identical they had a seizure and then
over the next three months they lose
all of their capacity to
for social interactions for eye contact
they begin
oh yeah it's scary i mean a lot of that
stuff is super scary so but so you go
into that also
i go in there and say and he tells me
these stories and he says he wants to do
something about it and does it seem
serious when he's saying that like
uh yeah he was dead serious okay and he
asked
um you know whether i would run a
vaccine safety commission then he asked
what i would do
and i said listen i don't think you have
to do a big political lift
all i think you need to do is open up
the databases and allow independent
scientists in there to actually look
at the science because the hmos have all
the vaccine data down to batch
for every child in america and they also
have the medical records so all you have
to do in fact you can do
now that is ai can do machine counting
and you can do cluster analysis
and you can figure out very very quickly
whether
all of these epidemics not not just of
you know neurodevelopmental diseases
like all the atd the adhd the speech
like the the reds in them though
um narcolepsy the asd and autism
oh yeah the allergic diseases food
allergies peanut allergies
oh it's crazy when you think about
asthma and all the autoimmune adult
asthma
what even adult asthma yeah well they
and they're all listed by the way on the
vaccine inserts
as vaccine side effects because the only
way that you can see you know they
passed this law in 1986
and made it illegal to sue a vaccine
company
for injury but you still can sue them if
they know of an injury that's caused by
their vaccine and they don't list it on
the side effects
400 injuries falling down the stairs
everything
well all the autoimmune diseases but
they're covering all their bases that
way
yeah but they're not allowed to list it
unless there's significant evidence that
is actually being caused by the vaccine
fda fda is not allowed to allow them to
list it
unless fda believes it's being caused by
the vaccine
so so you had so so you have this
meeting with trump just to get just kind
of going back to that
you have this in the meeting with trump
and and and you leave out of the meeting
kind of hopeful about it well
i said to him what do you want me to do
and he said we want you to announce
so a jared kushner escorted me
to the preschool scrum how tall is jared
kushner you think
he's uh he's about i think he's about my
size he's about six one okay
and i think you're like six one two i'm
about a little over six i'm reaching i'm
doing yoga too i actually did something
this morning
yeah well you start shrinking too on you
i mean
i told you the next 20 years of your
life are going to be a nightmare because
well you battle against it a lot i see
you at the gym all the time
yeah you used to yeah until it closed up
but i hear about you at the gym
sometimes
when it opened back up briefly the
trainer that i have is like oh i saw uh
bobby kennedy in there the other day
yeah i was like yeah he's in there um
um so you left out of there was it hope
oh yeah so then i went down and
announced it
talked to the perez and then uh
a week later fiser made a million dollar
contribution
to trump's inaugural
and then trump comes in and we continue
to have
some meetings with fouchy and you know
that he
he had set up that we're part of this
process and we're rolling
to get this thing started and doesn't
seem legit when you talk to him he
seemed like somebody did he seemed like
uh oh he's very very charming but he's
not he's
listen ouchy i'm about to publish a book
on fouchy
yeah and he's um you know he's basically
he's been there for 50 years so he's
like j edgar hoover and the only way
that you last that agency for 50 years
is by carrying water for the
pharmaceutical industry
and under his watch he's supposed to
prevent autoimmune and allergic diseases
under his watch chronic disease has gone
from affecting twelve percent of the
american population to fifty four
percent we take more pharmaceutical
drugs than anybody in the world we don't
increase
his prices so we it's we he's made this
country pharmaceutical nation yeah my
brother's allergic to sesame seeds
but you know exactly and the way that
you get
allergies is from the aluminum adjuvant
in the vaccine which is
meant is put in that vaccine to initiate
an allergic response
and it and so if you have a sesame seed
oil
as an excipient in the vaccine or if
you're
if you're eating sesame seeds when you
have that aluminum adjuvant in you
it can promote provoke an allergic
permanent allergy
and if you look you don't know anybody
who is my
age who has food allergies very very
hard to find i think it's one in
something like
1300 and today if you're born
after he'll have a football team yeah
you know what i'm saying everybody after
so any anybody who was born after 89
i think it's one and 12 now autism went
from one in ten thousand in my
generation to one in every 34 kids
and it's the same with all these chronic
diseases that are all listed
as side effects so the proof seems to be
right there
well that's correlation which isn't
actually proof but
if you actually go into the scientific
literature
the proof is there but now is that
science so whenever you talk to trump
you said okay let's open up this
this database right this information
because you said like
i said let's you know i said you don't
have to do
any heavy lift you don't have to go to
congress
you don't have to change regulations all
you have to do is open up the vaccine
safety data link which is
the medical records for the top nine
hmos and allow independent scientists to
go in there
and just open it up so they can start
publishing and did he do it
and no he didn't it's still locked you
know lockdown tony fauci make sure
nobody can get in there
and you know even when congress ordered
these two scientists called david
michael geyer
ordered them to go in there and they
they let them
into the place they they gave them one
study room
they would not allow them near a copy
machine they allowed them pencils
and they had to write down data and they
they cranked the heat in the room up to
and they you know stole their hard
drives and they didn't write it they
didn't
want anybody in that right right and
writings hard you've tried to you've
written a letter
it's like having a stroke the whole time
it's like i feel like it's [ __ ]
insane have you written something i mean
it's absolutely yeah
i do i i mean you might still write it
but
it's yeah it's getting uh
so anyway so anyway so big farmer
stepped in
and trump appoints pharma
pfizer's lobbyist to run fda
um scott gottlieb and eli lilly's lobby
is
alex azar to run hhs and as soon as they
came in they shut us down
and was that a big were you bummed about
that was i bumped
yeah i was very bummed i had a bit
bummed yeah
of course it was like within our grasp
you know good evening good afternoon and
other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you could watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah